[Music]
hi
and welcome everyone my name is
stephanie wetland
i am an officer
at the graduate school of business at
stanford and today we're having
the opportunity to speak to a number of
our in the mena region so thank you all
for joining us
and then the next um piece of
information i really want to talk about
is our
global community which i've already
shared and really when you look at
stanford's
opportunities there are over 60
regional clubs across the globe
um over 30 000
gsb alumni globally and you really have
an opportunity not only in this vast
community but also very deep connection
to individuals within the region so
today we're hearing from folks from the
media region
and uh if you're able to
get the opportunity to join the stanford
community you'll have
access to over 50 clubs and
organizations on campus
that represent many of the
countries around the world a very global
and diverse
community one of which of course would
be our
middle east and north africa club or the
meena club
so without further ado let's go ahead
and introduce our panelists
i think in this aspect we'll go in order
of um alpha order i guess so we'll start
with you itamar if you just want to well
for everyone
um if you just want to start with your
name maybe talk a little bit about your
journey to stanford
and then what you're currently doing now
that would be a great place to start
sure so hi everybody good evening from
the region
my name is itamar orr
my journey to stanford was mostly driven
by my will to study education
and management together hoping to be
an influential person in education
design
if the one thing that attracted me most
in stanford was
the ability to design
a inter-disciplinary
curriculum for myself and really
learning the best from the med school
engineering school history school as
well as business and education schools
currently i'm working part-time as head
of data science in a
music production company called
distrokid and
part-time teaching data science both
in universities and in high schools in
government programs
thank you so much thank you um i'll skip
muhammad who may be joining us later
we'll see and we'll start with muhammad
or
meki i think by the way hamilton is is
i see him as a participant so
to pull him in allison will probably
thank great
thanks i'll just jump in before uh
muhammad who we overlapped actually when
he was an undergrad
and i was i was doing my mba in 2010. um
i'm so i'm i'm based in uh in dubai uh
i'm currently actually sitting in
chicago
where i'm from uh spending the summer uh
i
work in the uh tech and and startup
uh space uh which i didn't before uh the
gsb and that was one of the reasons why
i really wanted to go out to
stanford was to immerse myself in that
environment i got a chance
to you know work at a at a startup while
i was uh while i was at the gsb
took some fantastic courses uh related
to that and venture capital and and
starting a startup
and i came out to dubai and uh started
an e-commerce company
in 2011 and then in 2013
uh co-founded astro labs which is what
i'm still doing to this day
which is a a platform for uh
entrepreneurs and
and tech startups with co-working spaces
and training programs
uh and helping with recruiting and a
bunch of different stuff along the
uh enablement of the tech and startup
world so that's been my
my uh my journey uh over this last
period
i've actually had the unique pleasure of
being able to see the space in dubai so
it was quite wonderful
thanks for your generosity and
and giving us a tour me when i was in uh
travels
it was great to see you yeah great to
see you too
uh richie you want to go ahead sure
sure uh thank you so much for inviting
and i'm really excited to
be of any help to the new people that
are attending the webinar
so to give a brief background about
myself i'm dr uchidana i was
born and raised in the middle east i was
born in libya in north of africa
and then her family moved to dubai in
the early 90s when the libyan sanctions
happened
so i did part of my schooling from libya
part of it from dubai and then i went to
medical college in india
and i was really passionate about low
cost medical devices and
innovation and also that's the reason i
pursued my mba from stanford
and one of my highlights there would be
the stanford biodesign program that i
took
because it really helped me to really
think about the ideas and think about
them in a way that
i could address all the stakeholders and
actually commercialize things out of
that
so that was really exciting and i'm i'm
right now in dubai
we have our own family business and i'm
also investing actively in the health
care sector
thank you thank you thanks so much
and yeah yeah if you want to go ahead
and introduce yourself please
of course thank you very much i hope you
can all hear me loud and clear but let
me know if there are issues
so my name is yaya for those that don't
speak arabic if you speak arabic
obviously
so my i think three things attracted me
to the gsb
program or stanford in general i knew i
wanted to also do a technical degree so
i was looking for joint degree programs
so
like damar said like at stanford you
can't go wrong because
regardless of whatever programs you
choose it's typically one of the top
schools in
the us or in the world so i got a great
education out of it
second was also the location so being in
silicon valley and
kind of drinking from the water of
silicon valley and stuff and learning a
lot
about that was also quite helpful um
and third i think the biggest takeaway i
got from the gsp was actually
more the personal growth aspect so me
learning more
about myself the touchy feely again
aspect which
gsb is famous for so thinks of why am i
angry why am i upset
why i feel overwhelmed where is that
coming from
so being a bit more introspective and
that
really is helping me even in my career
today and also in my personal life
um so that i would say that's actually
the biggest thing i took away from the
gsb and happy to talk more about that
if there are questions wonderful
thank you so much yes um touchy
feely as it's more informally known but
for those of you on the
um call you you might see it on our
website or
whatever uh listed as interpersonal
dynamics so
the two are synonymous all right thank
you
all um all right so mo well um
we might as well go ahead and let you do
thank you so much yeah i'll keep it
short good evening and good morning
everyone um
mohamed almo man class of 2015. um
also i have a longer history of stanford
i was an undergrad graduated in 2009
um currently based in dubai um nice to
meet you all i
believe i mean i know muhammad mekki we
overlapped at stanford
for some time and in dubai as well but
this isn't the first time i do one of
these events and i'm really excited to
meet
uh people who are interested in the gsb
and more than happy to answer questions
uh about life pre gsb post gsb
what you know what role it played in my
professional and personal career
um so yeah looking forward to chatting
with everyone
great um i hope for those who joined
today
um you can get a taste of how
impressive uh the alumni community
is the diversity we have a great group
of panelists who have joined us today
really a representation of um
the the breadth and diversity of our
alums and the strength of the community
across the globe so
thank you all from the mena region for
being here
um all right so with that being said
again
for those of you who have joined today
feel free to put
any questions you have in the q a box
and
these folks are at your disposal i'll go
ahead and start off
with just a basic question and and any
one of you can
chime in and share your thoughts but uh
it might be helpful for people to
understand what it was
that got you thinking about stanford and
more specifically an mba
can any of you speak to why you pursued
an mba and why stanford
yeah i can i can go first yeah so
uh i was a doctor so i studied medicine
prior to business school and
and i was really passionate about
low-cost medical devices i
i was publishing a lot of papers
presenting a lot of papers and i really
wanted to commercialize these devices
but that was back in 2008 so even the
startup ecosystem hadn't developed very
well especially in india
and even the best of professors in
medical college would not really
understand the language of business they
would like
rather publish one more paper in a peer
review journal then go ahead and start a
new company so it was
only about understanding the language of
business and then
the main highlight of stanford was the
stanford biodesign course
because a lot of medical device
innovation comes out of that course
in that course you have doctors phd
students mba students
engineers lawyers everybody comes
together to solve for unmet clinical
needs so that was
one of the being attractions for me for
taking the mba program and the biodesign
program as well
thank you thanks so much
um does it tomorrow mow especially since
the two of you both did joint degrees
want to talk a little bit about that
exploration process
i'll say a few words about it
i think there's some schools that are
very very strong like uh
this might here sound like a wild card
to some but uh the sleep
science in stanford is the most advanced
sleep science
in the world and i believe sleep science
is very well correlated to education
because adhd is correlated to sleep
quality
so if you ask me what school would i be
able to
learn about the science of sleep while
the educational impacts of sleep and
working on a product that improves
toddler sleep there's nowhere else you
could do that
okay so thank you
thank you yeah is the question more
around like
why gsb or why business school um
both uh why you were exploring
yes business school and then why
stanford
so both your exploration about
so for for me i think the i mean
it doesn't sound great but it was kind
of like what it will
a lot of people in consulting do anyways
so i was kind of
uh falling to peer pressure in a way but
at the same time it was
i started to feel like a lot of my work
experience was making me
it was a bit focused and i started to
feel a bit narrow-minded in terms of
industry and exposure
and i thought like really um getting out
of that bubble
and i realized that everywhere you go to
is some sort of a bubble because
stanford's a bubble and
where you're working as a bubble but i
wanted to break out of the bubble that
bubble that i was currently at and i
thought it was a great way to
to get to know people who are in other
industries who are doing different
types of work to see that there was more
um
to what opportunities existed out there
beyond what i was
currently focusing on and then and then
why stanford i think for me
personally i just found that
i i already had a history with stanford
so i felt it was a good fit
um and one thing i really appreciated
and it was confirmed to me a while like
once i got onto campus is that um
there's a lot of really smart and
talented people but what really
impressed me is
people tend to be pretty pretty down to
earth um
and i really appreciated that i didn't
feel like there was any presumptuousness
in class or on campus and
i just felt like it was a bit more
laid-back than maybe some other places
that
that uh that other people would consider
so for me
it seemed like a good cultural fit and i
really appreciated that
thank you thanks so much um
there is actually a question in the q a
that kind of relates to
you know maybe why stanford over other
schools so well you can't speak to
another school necessarily
were there um certain elements about
the stanford gsb that spoke to
any of you really um in terms of being a
differentiator
uh maybe i'll i'll say a couple words on
that um one of
one of the main reasons that i uh had my
my sights on on stanford was
to be immersed in the you know the
startup and tech ecosystem
um as i knew that that was something
that i wanted to learn more about
explore and potentially pursue
um in the later part of my career but um
i i think
beyond that it was although i didn't do
a second
degree while i was on campus i thought
that the
accessibility and the the structure of
the program
enabling um the
everyone to expand beyond the business
school actually and take courses outside
uh really drew was was really kind of
interesting to me because i
i made it for instance a habit just
about every single
quarter i took a course outside of the
gsb um
and i did everything from a literature
course on mark twain
to a phd religious studies course that i
took
with you know foremost expert on chronic
studies
to a you know a political science
and uh you know uh uh course that was
that was deep on the on the region to a
language court like i just
like i was able to each quarter take
something like the best of from each of
these different departments in areas
that i had a personal interest and
passion for so that was that was a big
driver for me and something i really
look fondly on
uh when i when i think back on my
experience yeah
it's great i think i think it's
important that um the folks on the call
know that that is a
big asset of uh the stanford community
as a
as a whole and that um not only do you
get the value
of the gsb in the business school
education but
you do have access to all other
professional graduate programs or
schools on campus
and that you are able to take
units outside of the business school to
even apply towards your degree so
as muhammad mentioned yes you can you
can certainly do that on a quarterly
basis and
kind of expand your horizons and learn
more about what the
greater institution can provide for you
so thanks for sharing that
can i can i chime in here quickly and
just say a quick word
so on that too so i wrote in the chat to
that question that
obviously i wanted to learn by doing uh
stanford affairs
offers a lot of experiential learning
and we've heard from dr roshi how she
enjoyed her experience it was quite
formative
to me another let's say more social
aspect
was the diversity of the place so
obviously at the time i was younger for
some reason and being very open here
i was nervous about the fact being
muslim and going to a non-muslim country
or place
and being viewed as like a terrorist or
something and
i was quite insecure and worried about
that but
what really pleasantly surprised me was
that california
by nature is well known for its
diversity
at least like the bigger parts of
california but the gsb community itself
was very very diverse
i felt very respected and appreciated
for who i who i
am and i could be my full self without
needing to pretend or put on a mask
um for people would just respect
whatever
my beliefs were or whatever i chose and
we could have open conversations even if
we disagree
uh respectful conversations just to
better understand each other
um for me i have again being fully
transparent and open i have
have not had the pleasure of meeting
someone from israel israel before and i
remember
having a lot of conversations with my
israeli classmates
that were very enlightening and helped
me develop also as a person
um so that's just like what for me
i suspected stanford would offer and was
very very pleasantly
surprised and it was very formative for
my journey and experience as well
thank you for sharing i appreciate that
um all right let's see we have a few
other questions that have popped in here
um let's talk about muhammad asked a
question about how beneficial is the
stanford's alumni
network both in saudi and in the greater
gcc
region um can anyone speak to that what
your experience has been like
as part of the community
um i guess i've been around the longest
[Laughter]
well i i i find you know
one of the considerations is is always
you know
who who who's going to be there actually
i'm i have i had a different story than
which is that i grew up in the us um and
uh
one of my goals for post-business school
was actually to
uh take a risk and go you know live in
in in the middle east
um and and try my hand at doing some
work there
so i you know i had i had a journey of
basically working and everything and
living in the us and then
you know going to the gsb and then
making the transition out to dubai
and i one of the considerations was
honestly it's it's a it's a smaller
alumni network um you know because of
the class size and just because of just
you know just the number of people that
are out um
for me i know that you know every single
person that i met
both prior and like you know during the
during business school that was
that was part of the alumni network from
the region um
just i just felt like a really good you
know kind of like cultural fit
and and connection with and found that
even
in the years post that there's a there's
a strong
um the the strength of the network i all
i can compare to is kind of like
undergrad versus grad school
which are obviously different beasts and
you know different phases in life
but it's just um there is an instant
connection because i think it is a
tighter knit group of people also across
the
geographies so you know whenever i'm in
uh saudi which uh you know um it's
pretty often
uh there's i can immediately plug into
you know the the uh the saudi gsb uh
community
um and that's been really you know post
uh
has been one of one of the best parts of
being you know affiliated with the
school is just like
uh and then the new people that are
coming along so for me it's more of like
the the depth of bonds and the and the
connection
um which was surprisingly you know uh
um uh strong and and positive uh
much beyond just like uh oh we kind of
went to the same school there's really
an outpouring of support and
and and uh a kindred spirit yeah
i love how you mohammed you know i
usually
will share oftentimes that the strength
of the alumni
community is really representative of
the number of people who are committed
in you and dedicated to you and i have
heard resoundingly
in all my conversations and travels how
deeply
and tight-knit that community is and i
think that
is what speaks to the value
of the stanford alumni community so
thank you for sharing
uh and i know yeah and that too i just
wanted to add oh sorry yeah
i just wanted to add because i i've
attended a lot of the stanford alumni in
saudi
saudi um events and it's a very
deep-rooted
community the stanford saudi community
is i remember
alumni attending from like who graduated
from stanford in the 70s
people who are like very senior people
in government and even some of the
younger people as part of the alumni
network are very passionate about the
work that they do and
they really are one of the most active
um alumni networks around
um so i think i think for for anyone
who's based in saudi and
and is considering gsb and stanford more
broadly
um you'll definitely find a support
network and a network of people who
are doing really impressive things there
thank you so much
um i want to ask a question that joey
put in the
q a and richie this is for you
specifically so
um just some information around if you
could elaborate more
on the projects or outputs of your bio
design course or just talk a little bit
more about that certainly that sparked
some interest and i'm sure others would
like to hear
a little bit more about um that
experience
sure i think like that that was a really
life-changing experience so at
the stanford biodesign course uh the
father figure there is tom fogerty who
is like
a very well known med tech innovator
says developed a number of companies and
there are so many
alumni that come out of the stanford
biodesign program who
who are like later on inventors and
investors into medical device companies
so there's an
entire ecosystem that promotes a lot of
med tech innovation
for me particularly the highlight was
that i got an opportunity to lead a trip
to china
and we got the nih grant under the sea
idea program for stanford for that so
that was
that's the first grant i ever got from
the u.s government it was really a big
highlight for me and we we led this
trip to china and worked in most the
most remote parts of china and
work in the government hospitals there
and it was mainly about finding needs
finding unmet needs and thinking about
crazy ideas to solve those unmet needs
so that was
the main highlight for me having to do
that trip to china
that's wonderful thank you so much for
sharing
uh let's see here i know some of you
folks are thank
you for answering in the q a for some of
you who are doing it there
i realized doing that actually dismisses
the question
so it's still very open and we don't get
to talk about it so so i do apologize
that's why i'm going to them
like what might i have missed that we
can address um
you know more broadly so um yeah yeah i
know you think
there was one i just answered on a joint
degree with hks
so yeah can anyone speak to that i know
i can say and i'm sure you answered was
that yes there are opportunities to do
that especially with the harvard kennedy
school of government we do have a joint
degree was there anything else that
folks wanted to elaborate on
either colleagues peers who you know may
have
pursued degrees outside the gsb in
partnership
let's see if the clown wouldn't let me
go yeah go ahead
sorry i i i have a few tips and tricks
if anybody's wanting to hear them but
i'm more interested to hear what yaya
has to say
um i'll say in general there are degrees
that are funded
in meaning that you could extend your
scholarship too and there are degrees
that are not
there are degrees in which you cannot
extend your a period of learning and
there are degrees which you can
and there are degrees which you need to
apply before business school and there
are degrees that you need to apply
after so uh if you want to talk more
about it i'd love to get into the
details
that's a great point and i know that you
did the um
i guess maybe mamba is one way that they
described at the na mba which
is an opportunity for candidates to
actually get a two for one so you can
complete both degrees in the time it
takes to
do a two-year mba but
you're right there are other programs
and joint degrees which
uh you must or typically take a little
bit longer whether it's another quarter
or more
um yeah yeah did you want to add to that
was there anything else you wanted to
share
so just wanted to confirm what i
probably uh have said in writing that
hks is definitely one of the more famous
uh or one of the popular let's say uh
joint degrees and you do split your time
doing your mba at stanford and then your
public administration degree at harvard
and many of our classmates i'm sure we
all have classmates who probably did it
if the program was there while we were
at stanford maybe one additional thing i
i would add to like what seemed to be an
advantage about the joint degree
uh at least in my case in engineering is
that you could apply you needed to apply
to both schools
so let's assume you got into one it kind
of gives you another chance to apply
again
while you're there and you do get the
option to
you get a choice of where do you want to
start do you want to start into
engineering school do you want to start
into business school
i personally chose to start in business
school because i wanted to get
three years of exposure to business
school um
and i don't regret my decision at all i
think it was the right choice for me
um yeah so so i personally benefited
a lot from from the joint degrees but
that being said i know a lot of
classmates that still took engineering
classes
still still were interested to to get a
bit more technical
we've heard from others as well like
they like explored whatever kind of
sparked their curiosity which is great
at stanford
so there's still room for that you don't
need like a full cs degree if you just
want to take a cs class
but i went in knowing that i wanted a a
like graduate technical degree so so
that's why i pursued that path
great thank you thanks so much um
one open question here that we can
adjust it is broadly speaking
and you might have some info just to
right here but um can you speak to the
trends in tech entrepreneurship
in mina um and i guess also well more
specifically
um ahmad is asking and banking in
fintech which
many of you may or may not have
expertise in but yeah
well i you know i think it's um if we
just even look at the the evolution over
the last handful of years it's pretty
amazing to see the growth
in the entrepreneurial sector
in in the region across across the board
so
um i know when when i came out to the
region after business school
and we were starting nemshi uh an
e-commerce company in 2011
it was like a very you know very rare
thing to get you know vc funding and to
build a
a tech company at the time
now i mean over the span of the last
seven i guess last eight years with
astro labs
uh we've we've worked with over 1 000
startups so
about 500 of which we've helped set up
in the uae and saudi in our co-working
spaces and about another 500 we've
trained up in different programs and all
this
and it's it's just the volume has grown
exponentially
um the sophistication and the types of
of uh
uh projects that are coming up um the
funding
uh that's available to founders uh
there's actually a mismatch right now
and that there's
actually more funding available and a
lot more on the table
than there are you know really standout
companies so if you are
a founder that has something quite
compelling
um it's actually great time valuations
are high you can kind of get
you know you get funded and you can grow
a team and i think that
the sectors that were talked about i
mean especially fintech right now is
actually one of the hot sectors uh
that's uh
uh particularly in saudi there's a lot
of regulatory opening up that's
happening
that is converging with you know
interest in this sector and people kind
of jumping in from more traditional
banking and such uh to be able to start
up companies
so it's just generally it's an exciting
time to if you're if you're interested
in tech and entrepreneurship
getting equipped with the you know the
experience from you know the the bay
area and kind of the stanford experience
and and uh getting immersing yourself in
that and then
uh bringing it out and then applying it
and and
growing something in the region it's a
fantastic time to do it
thank you thanks anything anyone else
wants to add on that i think you covered
a lot of great
uh insights
okay um i guess one question i have that
might be helpful for folks who are
dialing in in the mena region
is um how has the mba
um or what have the benefits of
the mba been for each of you in
your regional ecosystem so kind of like
the value of it what what has that
felt like what's that experience been
like for you post gsb
um you tomorrow why don't we just start
with you and if you can talk to
you know um then i'll be candid here
um coming from the middle east i had
some
fear that if i learn uh american
business practices
too well it might not fit back in where
i need to perform
um and uh i
have found that the staffer community
was
quite interested in learning about the
cultural aspects and helping us
perform where we need to perform and i
think especially
it might be in the smaller details in
the later groups that are associated
with the region or in the in the alumni
groups
so boiling down to how i felt when i
came back
um i think i've had definitely more
confidence to approach big ideas
but also i've i've been i've been uh
pushed down by some people
who said uh you went to learn in a fancy
school instead of
uh you know working hard and i
and and i that i think that is common in
our region maybe less common in other
regions that type of perspective
but the tools uh
we we got were are priceless and i use
them every day
and um when people work uh
with you and they notice you have tools
that work
if it's communication tools if it's
management tools
um if it's just the ability to
communicate across differences
in product engineering um
i think it really gave me a a wide level
up on on
almost everything i have to do my daily
job um i
even answered emails differently
[Laughter]
it's great hopefully that answers the
question
yeah yeah does anyone have any
additional insights they want to share
and how that's um played out for you
in your regions
well i think maybe just one point about
like it for me it was more of a personal
journey
so i didn't go to stanford to learn
about mina
or to learn about how to do business in
the middle east
it was actually like how to like it's
like almost like rediscovering
um myself a bit and and like
building my own tool kit um in order to
then
uh i mean to get to mars point even like
i noticed i was more
uh willing to take risks
willing to think bigger and that came
from both
formal things that we learned as well as
honestly just being inspired by your
peers and just seeing like wow
even coming into business school this
person has done
x or she's done y and like uh you're
just like well you know what what am i
wasting time for like
let me just go and just do it i mean
what's the worst thing that can happen i
think
that attitude i didn't come into the gsb
with i really
it was a powerful one of my friends who
knew me well from before to after
also will notice they're like yeah
something's like a little bit different
here something's changed
um and then very very practically
speaking
i landed from uh you know from
from the bay area into dubai and i
started i was with
uh i was with mckinsey for uh 11 months
and then i had an opportunity to you
know start an e-commerce company and you
know take
some funding old muhammad would have
never been
like oh you know you need at least two
years you know you've got there's so
much more to learn i can't you know
what who leaves like after like 11
months and like a new job and in a new
country
and then i you know but but my attitude
was just like you know what
worst case scenario it goes to zero it
doesn't work out
you know i go back and get another
consulting job or i you know do
something else
it'll be okay and i think that attitude
and then even post that the willingness
to then jump off
of that company and start another one
and all that
whole attitude was wasn't part of me
before i went to
the business school you speak to a good
um to one of the ethos of stanford right
and and the philosophy
of um the willingness and ability to
take risks
and um to not fear failure right to
really stretch yourself and step out of
your comfort zone we talk a lot about
that so i'm glad that that
is how you felt um the nba you know
broadened your your ability to
um think outside the box and explore
new opportunities knowing that you had a
support system right regardless of
where you landed so that's right if i
could add
i think for me similar to muhammad it
was also a personal journey
and i don't think i am as much of a risk
taker as he is at least not yet
my career has been all in consulting but
i've noticed lately the last couple of
years of also
um i think i think that the gsb
uh community and environment and mindset
has made me more interest
introspective and the way it manifests
itself for me
is is in really thinking about how i
define success for myself
because um i often felt the
you know peer pressure or just the
pressure of seeing so much success
around me
people starting companies selling
companies and
and i i realized at some point like
maybe the lesson for me wasn't so much
about following that trend but just
thinking about like what is it that
mattered to me and how do i define what
what is successful for me because
if i was always going to compare myself
to others i never would have been
i never would have been content put it
that way and something about stanford
just
gives you the it gives you the freedom
to sort of
chart your own path whatever that may be
and there are plenty of people i know
everyone thinks that everyone will start
stanford does a startup or goes into
tech which is great but there are plenty
of people who also choose to do
different things and i think
uh what i find admirable about all of
those people is that they've made like
very conscious decisions
which i think stanford empowered
empowers you to do yeah
well said thank you thanks
um one question posed in the q
a specifically for you yaya's how was
experience while getting married during
your studies and any tips for time
management
i think it's helpful to kind of look at
the personal aspect of the experience
too
so others can chime in yeah sure so
uh so an experience getting married well
so there's this co
course called uh paths to power and
negotiations take
no i'm just guilty um so that has
nothing to do with mary
with marriage whatsoever um it wasn't
planned
it just so happened that i met the right
person i was there
and um just hit it off and these are
things that just happened and
and um and it just worked out and i
couldn't
i wouldn't i wouldn't have it any other
way on time management
the reality is what i found happen and
that's a lesson i learned and kind of
it got cemented while i was at stanford
and it goes throughout my career
is uh that you end up just making your
choices it's simply put
you you get into this position where
you're trying to figure everything out
and try to make everything work
and do everything go to all events to
spend time with your
loved ones spend time with your family
and i don't know
have time for yourself watch tv or do
sports or whatever
but you end up realizing and get pushed
into a corner where
you get humble to realize that you only
have 24 hours in a day and you need to
choose
um but it's that that's exactly the
experience that
really helped me grow right because uh
it was also very fascinating and
surprising to see how much
well gsb sometimes often feels like a
bubble
but how much what you learn in that
bubble translates
to wherever your path might take you
after the gsp
so that's kind of the lesson i learned
there and the choice i made at the
moment was
that this is going to be the most
important relationship i have in my life
of course friends matter of course
classmates matter and
networking for work and career paths
matter but
at least i know i only want one wife and
and i just need to focus on that and to
make it work
so i spent a lot of time uh invest
invested a lot of time in that
relationship
and again i do not regret that choice i
remember it was a really tough
choice at times while there like there
were a lot of social events with the gsb
sometimes it feels like it's by diabolic
design
that it's set up that way so because you
start
like getting that fear of missing out um
but but that was exactly maybe the
lesson i needed to learn of how to make
my own choices that
like hamilton said are right for me
and are is what's what's right for me is
i definitely feel i made the right right
choice and the right call
yeah there definitely is this um sense
of
fomo as as you all call it fear of
missing out but
not sure whether this acronym existed
when you were here
but um when you were there but uh now
there's
jomo which is also the joy of missing
out so being able to take
you know joy in realizing that there are
things you can miss out on
so i've heard that term so they both
exist now
um all right
so let's see here um anna asked a
question that
which actually follows up on a comment
that you had met
um that you had made earlier um about
presenting your true self and i think it
speaks to
a lot of what the gsb can
provide for their students is that
opportunity to really
get to the core of who you are and to
explore your vulnerability um so
she's asking you know for all the
panelists and those who are willing to
chime in could you share a memorable
experience
about how gsb helped you reinvent
yourself while also staying true to
yourself
and it's a great question anyone want to
jump in first yeah i can i can start
with that so
one of the major highlights for me apart
from the touchy feely course which
obviously is
really life-changing was that
i got elected to be the cfo and
co-president of the meena club
and that was really meaningful for me
because even though i'm not middle
eastern but i was born raised in the
middle east
and having those elections and getting
elected to that position i think like
that really
made me realize that uh you can actually
stand for what you believe in yeah
that's wonderful i'm glad to hear that
yeah anybody else want to chime in
yeah i think we all want to say
something but we're just nervous about
stepping over each other
so i want to give space maybe i
shouldn't call on anymore
yeah yeah i'm going to cold call etamar
so so talking about jomo and fomo and
and the gsb
is is very intense probably the most
if you look at my calendar as a measure
it was the busiest time of my life
um and one of the nicest things
i had the opportunity to do is because i
did a joint degree i i did one more
semester
in which i i was i my class graduated
and i had time to go to the library
and go to the museums in stanford and
look into some more studies i did a
study
on some archived materials stanford has
from the invention of the multiple
question
test in 1907 all kind of stuff i really
wanted to do but never found the time
the gsp so
to me that was really a way of
alleviating this will to study and and
use the amazing resources because
earlier i would always choose to spend
time with the amazing people i met in
gsp
yeah i totally agree with itamar i mean
the calendar example is spot on i mean
sometimes you try to set up some time to
meet with someone just socially and
yeah you have to wait like two to three
weeks before like a time opens up for
both of you to meet up
or maybe that's just what everyone was
telling me but uh
either way i think it was uh it is
intense in a good way and i think
especially the first year
there's a lot a lot going on and
it's not just classes it's getting to
know people it's going to talks
it is really driven by fomo i think the
second year
you have at least for me i had quite a
bit more time and more flexibility to
sort of shape
you know the classes i would take and
how it's how i would spend my time
i personally like i i chose to spend
time just like
going to the gym going jogging around
stanford's campus so lots of like really
nice hills
on campus and i found for me that really
helped to re-energize me so
i there were plenty of times where like
i didn't go to certain social events but
i felt like
i think as yeah i was mentioning like
it's it's part of what helps shape you
to make those decisions to say there's
so much going
on i can't be everywhere uh at the same
time
so i think for me like there was a lot
of growth on campus and
really helped to shape who i am even
today i think
that's a great point um
i want to ask a question i think it
would be helpful for folks
um who are on today to hear about
you know what were some of the most
compelling
um either academic or learning moments
that you had i'd like to hear from each
of you but
i'll start with uh muhammad meki if you
can think back i know you're the one
who's it's been
the um greatest amount of time since
you've been back at school so
apologies for calling you out but
when you think back but were there
certain compelling
um academic or learning moments that
really stick out
to you yeah it's a true test to see what
what sticks over uh over the period of
time right
i think um the broader point i wanted to
make on this
and and and just generally some of the
stuff that was brought up earlier was um
this point about choices and about
actually going in
with a bit of a plan and not just going
in and getting pulled left and right
because you can be
i mean there's just so much happening
academically socially everything
so going in of course with an open mind
but also having some per
like doing that introspection beforehand
is super helpful
because then you get to think about what
is it that i want to get out
out of you know out of this experience
and so that i can be purposeful about it
right
so for me personally there was a
i came in much more introverted and i
would be the kind of person that would
have like you know one or two friends
and it wouldn't have the hamilton uh
problem of the two to three week
uh scheduling issue um uh
but but uh i think people are just
telling you that by the way
um uh the uh the
so i i i you know that was one one
objective that i did have and i i kind
of like
like spread my wings out and that and
that really helped me personally and on
the academic side
i knew going in that i wanted to deepen
my understanding
of an exposure to the tech and startup
sector
and so there's so many cool courses that
you can take but i was just like
every time something came up i'm like
okay i want to take you know formation
of new ventures i want to learn
how venture capital works for instance
from joel peter you know
i took uh you know different different
types of courses
that would feed into this objective that
i had to come out of the gsb with some
kind of understanding
um that that i think felt you know so
when i when i look back yes there were
the highlight courses of like
managing different difficult
conversations for instance how do you um
uh you know go into a very challenging
management you know conversation and and
and achieve the objectives that you want
and but at the same time it was this
like kind of quarter on
quarter at least every other quarter i
would have something with my specific
goal in mind and so i when i left
i can say okay i have a i have a good
handle about how this
uh this sector works now
great yeah thank you i'm gonna go in
order of uh
last since you've been so muhammad you
were first no
ruchi i guess i'll go with you thinking
about the distance
traveled if you can think back to your
experience what might have been the most
compelling
academic or learning experience for you
sure so i i made it a point to take the
most difficult courses so i took like
a lot of finance courses because i i
knew like that was my weakness and i
really wanted to get
a lot more in in terms of finance so
that was one thing but i think like
the one thing that i didn't expect at
all was at the end of first year then
when you have the executive challenge i
think that that's the memory that i
still have like english like all the
alumni come and they role play different
difficult scenarios and you have to just
like uh act a certain part and see like
what's the trigger that's bothering the
alumni or like
the role playing so that was really
interesting so in our case like it was a
very simple problem but like we couldn't
even understand that this is
something that has to be said during
this meeting so so that was really
really really uh a very good learning
experience just to understand like how
interpersonal dynamics work out and
what's uh like how you say certain
things and how it's it's perceived by
other people
right yeah catching you off guard right
you know you have a plan of what you
think is
to to be accomplished and then there are
certain things that
might uh sidetrack the conversation yeah
i've i've definitely observed many of
those executive challenge uh
simulations and it's a lot of fun
all right i'm gonna go to youmo
um yeah i think i think there's
i think about two things so one is i
really love the fact that we had so many
i'm not sure what the term was but i
guess to call them practitioners among
the
like among the you know the lecturers
and
and the professors so it was a lot of
like stories and a lot of anecdotes
and it really felt like we were steeped
in
you know we weren't just opening books
and studying but really like learning
from their experiences
vicariously and then and then linked to
that was
um because of you know being in silicon
valley
i thought it was amazing that you were
around so many for example like venture
capital firms
uh around like so much uh you know so
many exciting things going on where
people would come in guest speakers you
know view from the top where you had
like you know leaders of industry coming
in and giving
and giving talks uh people coming in you
know
hearing your pitches for startup ideas
and i think from all of that
i learned a lot just um not just in
terms of like what people are looking
for but how to conduct myself and carry
myself i think that
um is something that i i retain until
today and it's been it's been what six
years since i graduated but i don't feel
like that's going to leave me any time
yeah yeah a lot of those skills are sort
of the skills that you'll
utilize throughout your career for sure
all right uh yeah yeah you're next
yeah i'll be very quick since i know
we're short on time so
uh one of the most technical ones was
the the marzo financial modeling class
i i think that made me so far so much
fall in love
with excel and which i already loved
before the course
so but i feel much stronger in terms of
financial modeling and thinking about
that
so that was great um in terms of
personal obviously touchy feely i spoke
about that but also
paths to power was very complementary to
touchy feeling because it's kind of you
get to learn
how to be a jedi master and then you go
to the dark side so
you kind of get both experiences uh
but but it was very complementary and
again helped me figure out for myself
like which
what the who who is yahya and who do i
want to be moving forward with my life
thank you all right we'll wrap up with
you it's tomorrow if you have anything
to add
shortly first of all it's honored to be
here and thank you everybody i'll say a
word on that um
i i say the two top courses one is
negotiations in my opinion
really i think in helping myself develop
negotiation skills and my friends and
family
develop negotiation skills and and
thought
and the second one i would say is tax
optimization
and there are a lot of gains to be done
in tax planning
i had no idea about before the gs
very interesting that's great um
really appreciate all of your insights
today
does anyone want to put in one last verb
of advice
um to the folks who are on the call
today just as they're thinking about
this experience and exploring an mba
any last parting thoughts
well i do hope that this was helpful for
all of you who are able to join us today
i am i'll say this regardless what
you're thinking just
just apply and then
we say that a lot in the middle east
inshallah you'll get admitted and then
you can make your choice
and obviously you can ask a lot of
questions and we'll be there to answer
so just apply
i mean what's the worst that could
happen for justifying
that's right yeah you can't get admitted
if you don't even try
right so there's that
um very true i i know these folks
probably be more than happy to continue
to stay connected or help you
in your search again to the panelists
who joined us today
thank you so much it was so great to see
you i miss seeing you all in person
and traveling around the globe so i do
hope that i'll get the chance to be in
the region again very soon
um but really grateful for the time that
you took today
it means a lot to us and i'm sure it
does to all the
attendees who are on the call so thanks
again and
and i hope you all have a great evening
morning and whatnot
so thanks again